welcome back to 8701
so in this section we talk about
calorimetry and in contrast to
the discussion of tracking detectors
here
what we're trying to do is measure the
energy of the particles and we do this
by basically destroying them
the underlying context is rather
straightforward we have a particle
and we put a piece of material in front
of it such that it slams into it
and the energy deposited by the particle
is the energy
the measurement we try to to undertake
so in nuclear and particle physics
that's exactly what we refer
to as calorimeters so the detection of
particles by measuring their properties
through the total absorption in the
block of
matter the common feature
or the central feature is that the
measurement is destructive
so again in treating tracking detectors
we try to
minimally disturb the particle and then
calorimeters we try to destroy them
um the exception to this might be a muon
which might at higher energies deposit
only small fraction of its energy in a
calorimeter
or a neutrino which just fly through
without having any interaction
um but the the purpose is really to
measure energies
by destroying the particle and it's
widely used in all kinds of areas of
particle
nuclear physics neutrino experiments
proton decay experiments cosmic ray
detectors
collider experiments and so on and in
collider experiments specifically
the idea is to build the detector such
that it
completely surrounds the interaction
region such that you don't lose
energy from the collision um just
passing through
an un instrumented region
the detection mechanism can vary quite a
bit um
we use scintillators a lot we use
silicon in some modern detectors
we use uh with this ionization we use to
rank of detection
we use sometimes cryogenic cryogenic
detectors which are very sensitive to
very small energy depositions and they
can be quite useful
they are used in dark matter experiments
or in
neutrinous double beta decay experiments
for example
again conceptually you can differentiate
between
homogeneous calorimeters and sampling
color majors
the homogeneous calorimeters um
basically the entire absorber material
is equal or is the same as the detector
material
so an example for this is lead glass
which is often used
so what you do then in the calorimeter
is you
induce electromagnetic and nuclear
showers and then
the energy of the incoming particle is
converted into
photons and then what you need is a
photodetector which then measures
the number of photons being coming out
of your
of your detector material for this to
work
the detector needs to be transparent um
alternatively one can use sampling
experiments something detectors
where you have you know the the heavy
material being used in order to induce a
shower
and then the detection material in order
to count again the number of photons
so homogeneous calorimeter have
typically very good energy resolution
and the reason for this is that nothing
gets lost
everything is being measured in the
absorber which is the detector
but that leads them to some limitations
for example that the granularity of the
detector
is typically limited and then there's no
longitudinal information about the
shower development you basically have
one block
for example a lab block which is shown
here
the tungsten block which is shown here
are used for the measurement
right so you produce photons and so then
the photons need to be measured
and that that's done with photo
detectors um here
the requirements the range of
requirements is quite big sometimes you
want to be able to measure every single
photon so the
quantum efficiency needs to be quite
high in others
uh detectors you need to be able to put
this detector in a radiation hard
environment
and so that that then changes the main
types available are
the old-fashioned photo multiplier tubes
which actually become quite
sophisticated pmts
there's gas based photo detectors solid
state detectors
which are quite popular so called septum
silicon
photodetectors or some hybrid modules of
cells
so the energy resolution in a
calorimeter
um depends on a number of things as i
was saying
one measures the number of particles
being produced in a shower
and so that's just a counting experiment
and the uncertainty of that
um scales with the square root of the
number of particles produced or measured
and so here we have a square root n term
uh so the rel the relative energy
measurement has an error which is
with one over square root of the energy
and then there's more contributions uh
there's constant terms which come from
in homogeneities uh those are elements
where there's just no detector no
equipment in in the
direction of the of the particles those
can be
overlapped regions or regions where you
have two detector modules being glued
together
you don't measure there and that leads
to them in a constant term in the energy
resolution and then when you translate
the signal in
the the electromagnetic signals into an
electronic signal there can be noise in
use and that noise
then leads to a typical term which goes
with one over the energy
so very classical you have the three
components to the energy
three components to the energy
resolution one is this one over the
square root of the energy
one's constant and one is depending on
one over the energy
and so when you design a detector you
want to
place it such or design it such that the
most important physics you want to do
with this detector
is optimized towards those components
you